We can understand the ranking that we're going to assign to this hand,
by the way a Poker player would call out his hand,
when asked to reveal it.
So our player declares "Straight Flush, Jack high!"
That's all you have to know about the hand.
A straight flush, the highest ranking,
and then the tie-breaker.
All we have to know is that the Jack is the high card.
So the number 8 stands for straight flush,
and the number 11 stands for Jack,
and that completely describes the hand.
Here's another hand.
Let's see what our player would declare for this hand.
"Four Aces, and a Queen kicker!"
So, four Aces is the major rank, which is a 7.
Ace is card rank number 14,
and the Queen is card rank number 12.
So that's the complete description of the hand:
<7, 14, 12>
Let's do another one. What's this hand?
"Full house, eights over Kings."
So even though a King is higher than the 8,
The 8 is what counts more importantly,
because there's three of them.
So a full house is major ranking number 6,
then the 8 because there's three of them,
then the King, which is 13.
That's the remaining card.
That three element tuple completely describes this hand.
Here's another hand. How do we declare this one?
Our player has called "Flush 10, 8,"
describing the two highest cards in his hand,
because that's usually enough to distinguish the the hand
from all other flushes that might be out there.
But in actuality we might need all the hands to break the ties.
Now a flush is ranked number 5,
and in order to break the ties,
we look at all the cards in the hand.
Highest first, and working all the way down.
So something in there should be able to break the tie.
Although, it certainly is possible, although unlikely,
that somebody else has those five exact cards in another suit,
and it actually would be a tie.
There would be no tie-breaker.
Let's look at this hand.
Our player describes "Straight, Jack high."
That's all he needs to say,
because if it's a straight,
if you know Jack is the high card,
then you know the other cards have to be "10, 9, 8, 7."
So we only need two numbers to describe this.
4 meaning "straight," and then an 11 meaning "Jack."
Next hand, "Three sevens!"
Usually that's enough to disambiguate a hand,
but if we really need to break the ties,
then we would look at the next highest ranking card.
Next is the 5, and then finally the 2.
So to describe the hand,
we have the rank number, which is 3.
Then the 7's,
then the complete list of the five cards.
Next hand "Two pairs, Jacks and Three's!"
That describes most of the hand,
but we also need to compare all the cards,
including the two pairs,
but it's the highest ranking pair, first.
So first, the 2, meaning "two pairs."
Then, the 11 for the Jack (the highest of the two pairs).
Then, the 3 for the three's.
And now we need the final card.
I happen to have all of the ranks standing around,
so I use that as a stand-in for the final card.
Either way, that fifth card can completely disambiguate the hands,
if you happen to tie on the Jack's and the 3's.
Here our player declares "Pair of two's, Jack high."
That partially describes the hand.
Notice we lost the exclamation point.
He's not so excited about his hand this time.
So a pair of two's, that's down to ranking number "1."
Then the pair of two's is the first tie-breaker.
And then all of the cards in the hand.
Our final hand, and our poor player declares "I got nothing."
Now he's REALLY crying.
But sometimes nobody else has anything either,
and then we still have to decide among the players who have nothing, who wins.
And we just go in order of the ranks of the cards.
So "nothing" is 0.
And then the ranks of the cards
from highest to lowest.